okay let's get you ready to fight wait
what well multi-platform global
operation every fight live stream on the
dark web thousands of viewers placing
bets as we speak this is gonna take your
brand to a whole new level i think
there's been some sort of confusion i
like your spike face they're my guts
here usually you gotta fight your way to
central ring but viral style like you
found a line babe i'm not here to fight
it
okay i'm looking for my sister sue
never heard of her we just lost a fight
at the last minute so you get the next
slot
[Applause]
nice one helen
is he anybody in one of these
oh no no no no these are like low level
fights you're gonna be fighting
up there
i should also probably mention that
my name's not technically sean
what
what is it
it's
shanxi
yeah
you changed your name from shang to sean
yeah i don't i wonder yeah i wonder how
your father found you i was 15 years old
all right what is what is your name
change logic you're going into hiding
and your name is michael you want to
change it to
michelle that's that's not what happened
it's like hi my name is gina i'm gonna
go into hiding my new name is gina
yeah okay oh yeah you can hear me
you